welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar synthetic
antibodies the emerging field of Optimas
in diagnostic and drug discovery
presented by dr. Thomas call to Girone
president and CEO of oxygen my name is
dr. Susie Bao this and I will be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during your
presentation just simply click on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation just click on that ask
a question box and let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education credit
tab located at the top right corner of
your presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining those credits
without further ado please join me and
welcome in our presenter today dr.
Thomas cultured your own welcome sir
thank you and thank you for that
introduction and thank all of you for
attending the talk today as mentioned my
name is Tom Calderon I'm president and
CEO of a biotech company called a pigeon
for this talk i'm i hope i'm able to not
only educate but inspire some of you to
consider the technological possibilities
of using apt Murs in a wide variety of
fields and downstream applications our
bold and in-your-face mantra is simply
forget antibodies use app Demers
so I I started the company back 15 years
ago in 2004 we are a service provider
we're located in south-central
Pennsylvania and we have clients ranging
from startup biotech companies to
research academics to a big pharma like
Pfizer and Merck they approached us to
develop optimize for one reason and that
is either their antibodies are failed to
specifically target their antigen or the
at the antibody doesn't exist whatsoever
so against difficult targets or antigens
so they're considering alternative
platforms like app app Demers in their
downstream applications so I like to
segment this talk into four sections
first I will introduce app Demers
background of app Demers diagnostic
applications cell and tissue targeting
and delivery and also drug discovery
applications so what are app Demers
here's a short review paper that we
published after MERS are sometimes
referred to as synthetic antibodies but
they're not protein based macromolecules
actually I brought along this this prop
to illustrate the point if this
represents a single-stranded DNA or RNA
molecule depending on the sequence it
will fold into some sort of
three-dimensional structure it's still
nucleic acid but once it binds to target
we call that an Optima so they were
invented back in the early 90s and
targets can range from small molecule
targets to protein biomarkers
cells tissues viruses you name it and
they operate in a wide variety of
matrices including biological fluids so
here are some examples of optimal
structures or back in the early 90s of
success stories of a promoters against a
wide variety of targets X Y Z whatever
that may be and here are some examples
for example there's a suitor not
configuration against HIV the reverse
transcriptase there is an after mer it
takes the form of a cheek quadruplex
that targets thrombin there's a simple
hairpin Optima against t4 polymerase and
a stem blue bulge against a TPS MOU
molecule ATP so these are just some
simple structures of early examples of
after MERS that have been developed over
the years the literature has exploded in
terms of success stories in the last
five six years of after MERS targeting a
whole host of targets and antigens the
size of apt immerse are approximately
one-fifth the size of a typical IgG
antibody about 30 kill adults and
because of its smaller size ax as a
macro molecule it's much more
advantageous to have a smaller size
versus a bulky antibody in terms of
penetrating tissues for targeted therapy
also for bio sensing applications if we
tether or couple the the abbé de mer to
a biosensor surface because it's closer
because it's smaller macro molecule
instead of a large bulky antibody your
signal response on your bio sensor is
much much more improved
so the bio sensor community typically
love their their app Demers over their
baltic bulky antibodies on their on
their bio sense
okay
in terms of their biophysical
characteristics
affinity app Demers are are I have
comparable affinities to that of
antibodies but we're apt immers out
shiny antibodies is in specificity so
affinities can be in the in the nano
molar range load and in Imola range
depending on whether it's a large target
like a protein in some cases a picomolar
but in terms of specificity they are
much more specific than antibodies you
can minimize or eliminate cross
reactivity or false positive results of
using after MERS versus antibodies
simply because of weather of how they're
developed and I'll get into that a
little bit later and later in a slide
deck but here's an example of an app
demur that exists against the offline
versus caffeine to small molecules
typically small molecules are difficult
targets for antibodies but there's an
app demurrer that binds to theophylline
versus caffeine with ten thousandfold
greater specificity and the only differ
by a single methyl group so just a few
atoms and yet this app temir binds to
theophylline versus caffeine I don't
think you can do that with an antibody
in most cases also another advantage of
event optimize over antibodies is that
you can discover unknown or unique
biomarkers and biological samples for
example you can if you have a patient
sample or samples that are considered
positive for some pathology or some
disease by some clinical means and you
have another set of patient samples and
a biological fluid that is considered
negative we can develop after MERS that
respond to the pause
not to the negative and so once you have
that you can easily identify what the
biomarker is by by performing a pulldown
assay and mass spec analysis to identify
what the biomarkers are so afterwards
have that advantage to discover unknown
biomarkers that exists and biological
samples and patient samples in terms of
manufacturing cost or in production
there are a fraction of that of compared
to antibodies so I typically say pennies
on the dollar in terms of producing or
manufacturing apt murders versus
antibodies also optimized are much more
stable than antibodies you have a longer
shelf life so because there are nucleic
acids DNA or RNA you can back to the
model here you can heat to nature them
cool them down and they'll snap back
into shape
you can't do that with a with a protein
based antibody it turns into scrambled
eggs after you heat it so after Mars
have have that benefit as well in terms
of the longer shelf-life so also have
listed here on this slide is is what we
have displayed on our website called the
app to index it's a searchable database
that we provide to the scientific
community to see if an apt mer exists
you simply type in your target or
antigen of interest and and we can
provide the sequence of that app temir
the DNA sequence of the RNA sequence of
that app demur if it exists now it's not
an exhaustive list this is this is
information that we pulled from the
literature and again this is a resource
to the scientific community that we
provide on our website you know we're in
the business of developing custom app
tumors but this is a resource to see if
an app temir does exist against your
particular target of interest
so diagnostic application
switching gears here in terms of
diagnostic applications so we're all
familiar with the typical sandwich iliza
method using antibodies it's the gold
standard it's a it's a it's it's a
time-consuming multi-step approach using
primary and secondary antibodies there
are incubations washes capture steps
that it takes hours to complete we can
develop Optimas sandwich based after
MERS for this type of sandwich based
assay however we have developed
something that's superior to that of
Eliza's or sandwich based assays called
Abdul beacons and these are after MERS
that upon binding to a target reports an
output either a fluorescent output or
color metric output so in this cartoon
diagram on the Left panel you see a
generic apt amour structure a simple
hairpin let's say on one end of the
optima there is a fluorescent tag or
fluorescent probe in close proximity to
a quencher so in the presence of the
negative sample or the sample that
doesn't contain your antigen of interest
no reaction occurs however on the
right-hand panel in the presence of your
positive sample the quencher is released
and the you exhibit a fluorescent
response and this is a one-step in one
pot reaction and free in solution that
unlike Eliza's or sandwich based assays
there's no capturing there's no washing
you just simply read and we call these
app the beacons on this slide oh and
there's apt beacons as an overreaching
concept is an overreaching concept and
and there are different versions of app
2 beacons
in this particular version it uses an
allosteric ribozyme switch so so in the
top left diagram here it's an RNA
molecule there isn't a hammerhead
ribozyme motif the arrow that little
arrow that you see on on near the
quencher strand is the cleavage sites so
this is a naturally occurring self
cleaving a ribozyme that exists in
nature juxtaposed to that is the abdomen
or domain where where the effector
binding pocket occurs so in other words
if you have a particular target or
antigen that the abdomen recognizes it
binds to that pocket and upon binding to
that domain it causes an allosteric
conformational change that activates the
self cleavage event releasing the
quencher strand and thereby exhibiting
fluorescence so this is an allosteric
ribose which with fluorescent quencher
tags and this is one version of the of
the mechanism or the design of adaptive
beacon there are other versions in fact
in our in our we've exhibited this or
showcase this in a and a demo kit where
it's actually a a colorimetric reaction
there we can there is a fluorescent
version of this demo kit as well and
this targets as a demo this targets
theophylline the example I gave earlier
where theophylline the theophylline
sample turns blue alike the caffeine
sample that that remains negative and
clear but this can this platform this
diagnostic platform can be applied to
virtually any target small molecules
like the offlane and caffeine or protein
biomarkers cells tissues viruses you
name it in that
this is actually it uses that allosteric
ribozyme mechanism that i that i
mentioned earlier where on the left-hand
panel there's the off-state
it's a shape you know shape-shifting
switch if you want to call it that way
or actually an app to switch when it's
labeled we call app the beacons but it's
an it's naked version without the
fluorescence we call that app the
switches so in the presence of the
antigen or analytes the the the app to
switch turns on releases a and initiator
or trigger strand that initiates a
cascade of events implication events to
enhance the signal so this kid entails a
signal enhancement system to boost the
signal of for sensitivity so there's two
levels of amplification before final
color development we recently published
this an ACS biochem and this is the
actual nuts and bolts of that one-pot
reaction or this three-stage signal
enhancement system on the on the left
hand side is the allosteric ribose which
in the presence of target again we've
studied we've used as an example as a
generic example of the alpha and versus
caffeine the trigger that's released
after the reaction takes place initiates
a an X par reaction this is an
isothermal application reaction similar
to PCR but isothermal conditions so it
amplifies that that that signal through
this isothermal amplification reaction
generating multiple or many copies of a
DNA sign this is a DNA opto DNA app
design DNA's i'm there are many
different terms you can use but this
particular DNA xym has peroxidase act
like activity so like similar to HR
horseradish peroxidase so in the
presence of tmb on the right on the
third stage of this signal enhancement
system the common substrate for for our
peroxidase type enzyme it converts the
reduced state of TN b to an oxidized
state and this turns a into a blue color
so it's a color metric version so this
is a one-pot reaction again it's it's
one version of our app to beacon
platform where there's a signal
enhancement system free and solution one
pot reaction we can also develop these
app two beacons or convert them into we
can reconfigure them into different
platforms in terms of lateral flow for
point of care use and point of care
Diagnostics so lateral flow test strips
like the dipstick assays in pregnancy
tests we can use our app Demers in that
configuration or app two switches
to test for analytes so this that's
another platform to replace antibodies
because typically antibodies are used in
those platforms and there are groups
research groups that are developing
smart phone readers for these these
whether you're using a lateral flow that
has a fluorescent output or a
colorimetric detection system so a
smartphone arena that can read a
florescent app to beacon for example we
can employ that or even a color metric
reader for for yes/no answers or even
semi quantitative readouts this slide
here is a table of different targets and
optimized that have been developed
against those there
and targets and antigens most of our
customers and clients you know they're
hyper focused on on affinities can we
develop a tight binding Optima and yes
we can but affinity is not necessary a
prediction or predictive measure of
success for your downstream application
you know that's one measurement that we
take into consideration as we quantify
our after MERS I mean you can have a
high affinity Optima or any molecule
login for that reason but it's not
specific so so it's not selective so the
other thing that should be of concern is
how specific is it to minimize across
reactive and giving out false positive
results and also the limit of detection
the platform that you're using what kind
of limit of detection or sensitivity or
your are you achieving you could have a
high affinity AB de mer
and yet fails your downstream
application for example you know these
after Mars are polyanionic biopolymers
they're very sticky they and if you have
a positively charged target it will bind
to any positive charge short charged
target with high affinity so so the
trick is to develop a login and after
Merle again that that is not influenced
by those electrostatic interactions and
it's specific to the identity of target
and not as charged so depending on the
matrix and the platform detection those
are the factors that of that we we
consider in terms of the design and
execution of the development of our app
Demers and another example of
theophylline it has it has a low or
affinity it has a you know micro mole or
affinity that that's that's that's it's
not an animal or it's micro molar
affinity
but yet I mentioned earlier it has
10,000 graders ten thousandfold greater
specificity towards theophylline versus
caffeine and you can see here on this
table
for example the one target Plasmodium
lactase dehydrogenase it's a protein
target an Optima has been developed
against that target with 0.35 micro
molar affinity so a high-knee animal or
affinity but it has 0.5 femtomolar
sensitivity so you know depending on the
platform that you're using in terms of
detection if it's a if it's a validated
platform the rule of thumb that I
usually give is that it whatever the
affinity of the the sensitivity or the
low limit of detection is at least one
or two orders of magnitude one or two
orders of magnitude in terms of
sensitivity so affinity is one factor
that we we you know how tight does the
login or app demur buying to the target
but you also have to consider your your
specificity to minimize cross-reactive
false positive results and also your
platform in terms of detection in terms
of low limits of detection so those are
the other other parameters that we we
want to take into account as we design
the development of app Demers okay so
switching gears a bit
now I'll delve into cells and tissue
targeting and delivery applications but
before I get into that I need to take a
step back and introduce a concept called
directed molecular evolution it's it's
basically using principles of Darwinian
evolution but atom or like your scale so
let's say in this cartoon representation
of the of them of the process we have a
pot
of molecules or library of molecules of
different shapes here represented by
triangles squares and circles and
immobilized on a solid support like
let's say a column we have our target or
antigen of interest and so the idea is
that we want to we want to interrogate
this library fine find out you know fish
for those for that needle in that
haystack that needs a certain fitness
test in this case binding to the target
like a little lock and key type fashion
so if there there are shapes in there
that binds to to the target in a lock
and key fashion those are our binders
our winners that we want to propagate
for another generation so we collect
those binders and granted the first the
first random library there's going to be
one or more a very few percentage of
molecules that meet that criteria or
that fitness test and so the vast
majority of the library are failure
shapes in this and this particular 'td
but the rare molecules that do exist are
that bind to the target are collected
and propagated and we can introduce some
sloppiness to the process you know
introduce some mutation slight mutation
to explore different contours of shape
to enhance its binding ability towards
the target of interest so after multiple
generations of this process of screening
partitioning binders from the non
binders and amplification we enrich this
library from a random state to a more
homogeneous states a polyclonal state if
you will that that has a response to the
target so this is the basic concept of
directed molecular evolution again we're
using principles or their winning
evolution but I'm on a molecular scale
and we can apply this concept to
all of the nucleotides single-stranded
DNA or RNA so these molecules are are
synthesized on a on a all ago
synthesizer a DNA machine and automated
DNA machine to generate a library of ten
to the fourteenth or ten trillion
different randomized molecules so ten
ten trillion different randomized
sequences each one will fold into a neat
shape and so we're exploring that
library interrogating that library
against the target of interest in this
case there here's a generic target that
I've shown this this example this
schematic flow chart here the molecules
that don't form the correct
three-dimensional shape that that binds
to target are discarded the ones that do
buying are collected and amplified by
PCR so polymerase chain reaction to
amplify those binders and if it's an RNA
library that we're exploring or
interrogating then we're using rt-pcr
reverse transcriptase or reverse
transcription and PCR so after multiple
generations of this process of enriching
the library we can clone and sequence
and test individual candidates in terms
of their in terms of affinity and
specificity now to eliminate cross
reactivity to you know the components in
your and your matrix whether it's it's a
blood sample saliva sample urine sample
or even even counter targets that are
similar to your target biomarker but are
considered counter targets we would
introduce a step here where we would
expose the library first to that matrix
or to that environment or to encounter
targets and anything that binds to that
any of the components or the milieu of
components and that sample will be
discarded what's leftover is then
exposed to your tart target so in that
fashion we ensure that we're enriching
for molecules that are specific to your
target so there's a positive selection
step and there's a negative or counter
selection step involved as well that's
not shown here on this diagram so with
that simple concept on paper it's simple
but believe me I've been in the field
for the last 25 years there are tricks
to the trade that we employ to ensure
success we have a pretty high success
rate in terms of a write what wide
variety of targets but we have
experience in targeting small molecules
proteins tissues peptides cells you name
it and so then the next few slides I
want to show you some examples or a
potpourri of examples of projects that
we've worked on that some information is
redacted but the some of this data is
also an internal results that we've
generated and our lab that's outside of
our non-disclosure agreements with with
our with our clients and customers but
here's one project in particular it's
against targeting a prostate-specific
membrane antigen for prostate cancer so
we know that you know these are we use a
circular DNA library and the reason we
circularize the libraries that we want
to avoid any degradation from nucleuses
that may be present in this in vivo
environment and so most of the xod
most of the nucleases that exist in vivo
or exonucleases and so in order to to
protect the ends of the DNA
exonucleases we simply just coupled it
together tightly together into a
circular floor mat so we developed the
design this library to be circular in
nature and we expose this library to the
parental cell line for our negative
selection step and any mouse and any
molecules that that bound to the
negative cell line were discarded what
was left over that did not bind was
exposed to our transfected cell line and
that expresses this this bio marker on
the cell surface and whatever bound to
that is collected and amplified and we
regenerate the circularized library so
after multiple generations of negative
selection followed by positive selection
we enriched the library to respond to
the to the positive cell line or the
transfected cell line expressing the bio
marker and in terms of analyzing the
characteristics of this enriched library
we used flow cytometry so this is so we
labeled the library with a fluorescent
tag and we went through 19 generations
of enrichment so these are the flow
cytometry results against the negative
cell lines or the parental cell lines
the PC PC 3 cells and you can see g0
versus G 19 g0 indicates the initial
random pull and G 19 is the enriched
library after 19 generations through
that process and there's no clear
there's no real shift or significant
shift to the right of this of this
diagram of flow cytometry tracing
however when we use that same comparison
on the positive cell line that that
expressed the piece
ma or the PSM a biomarker you can see
there is a shift of the enriched library
the g19 library compared to the the
randomised control so we were confident
that that we have something here in
terms of a response specifically to the
transfected cell line so that was one
project against a cell surface marker
here is another project and we by the
way we did clone in sequence the
previous project and obviously I won't
be able to show you that data but here's
another another project against an
intracellular target where we selected
an apt aware that bound to an
intracellular receptor and we have we
we've quantified or monitored the
enrichment of this library using
real-time PCR and quantitative PCR and
here are shown the real-time PCR
tracings and the melt curve analysis of
those different samples in short what we
found is that these the enriched library
had a hundredfold more preference
towards the intracellular target versus
the control cells that we've tested and
we again further we cloned and sequence
that library to further analyze those
those app temir lose monoclonal after
merck candidates but yeah actually here
i have a slide indicating we also looked
at a labeled than riched
the enriched labeled library under
fluorescent microscopy conditions on the
left hand panel you see a the phase
contrast image of these cells versus the
fluorescence in the same area now these
are against the the negative cells or
the
the negative cell line in this
particular project and so we don't
expect to see obviously fluorescence
here so this is our negative control
however in the positive cell line we do
see fluorescence targeting these these
cells that expresses that this
intracellular receptor so these are just
some examples of cell based selection
projects that we've entertained over the
years and now now let me dive into drug
discovery applications of baptists so as
we all know from laboratory bench to
pharmacy shells it takes approximately
10 to 15 years to bring a drug to market
and costs over 2 billion dollars it's a
long an expensive process fraught with a
low success rate because there's only
one one in a thousand and every thousand
candidates that are passed testing and
animals actually one makes it into human
clinical trials so a very low success
rate even after all those years and all
that capital investment into the process
and this is this has been in the
paradigm of the drug discovery
development
ever since the pharmaceutical industry
has been in existence for the last 100
hundred fifty years so and the reason
for this why it's law long and
time-consuming and expensive process is
because you have to have some sort of
knowledge of the of the pathology that
you're trying to treat and and develop
validated in vitro or test tube assays
that you can test your drug candidates
and any positive that you get from there
then you test in animal models and and
and finally into human clinical trials
so now the the molecules that are tested
are either derived from nature the
typically the small molecule some small
organics
small molecules are either derived from
nature or chemically synthesized at the
laboratory bench and again these are
tested in these in vitro test tube
assays any positive hits you get from
their intestine and and human animal
models that mimic the human form of the
condition before clinical trials now
they positive more times than not you
get negative results and so you have to
go back and from in vitro tests and vivo
studies you have to tinker with the
molecule it's a trial and error approach
back and forth time and money so it's a
very expensive long long and
time-consuming process of to to develop
candidates or drug candidates to market
however what if we were to eliminate the
in vitro assays and test tube assays and
do drug discovery directly in an animal
model if you're able to do this then
you're one step closer to human clinical
trials they're thereby saving
significant time and money in the
process of developing drug candidates
and so what if we were able to take a
library a molecular library so I showed
examples of you know in vitro and and
cell based assays but what let's say
let's say we go to a whole animal model
that mimics the human form of the
disease let's say it's you know a tumor
a cancerous tumor and we administer this
of this library to the animal either
tail vein injection or some other route
of administration and in this cartoon
example you know we collect the area the
the tissue of interest there's a cross
section of tissue here and there
a area within that cross-section of
tissue where your pathological marker
exists your biomarker exists you know
that that black region there it's that
say that's your cancerous region if we
take a biopsy or extract that that that
abnormal tissue away from your normal
healthy tissue and extract any any
ligands or or or molecules that that are
found at that site and we can amplify
those molecules and the molecule is
actually that in that library that your
that you administered the molecules that
cross react with normal healthy tissue
will be left behind so the normal
healthy tissue will act as a sink to
minimize cross reactivity or
side-effects if you will because we're
using again the principles Darwinian
evolution but in this case in a whole
animal model we're taking the binders
that specifically target the
pathological area and leaving behind
those molecules that cross react with
normal healthy tissue so those molecules
are allowed to be propagated and amplify
amplified and then we reject into the
and to another animal as mimicking the
same form of the disease and we were we
apply this process over and over again
to enrich the molecular library from a
random States or more homogeneous
polyclonal state that that
preferentially targets that that
diseased area so in drug discovery as
all of you know delivery is always an
issue so selection and whole animal
models solves the delivery issue that's
it minimize off target effects so you
can use your your your your molecules
that target that specific tissue these
after MERS
and use it as a vehicle to carry a a
toxin right if you have a toxin on one
end this is a vehicle that carries your
cargo to that that diseased area
and the case I used what was cancer so
toxin to destroy that that cancer org or
really or even a radioisotope or even
possibly a drug a small molecule drug
that failed clinical trials for four
off-target effects you can possibly
rescue that that drug in terms of having
minimizing the losses off target effects
by using a a molecular bullet if you
will to carry that that cargo that cargo
to your your site of interest so so you
can use these as as as carriers to
specifically target your your disease
the area or your pathology now in terms
of using the same process to develop
pharmaceutical compounds or drugs in
general unique chemical diversity ok
chemical diversity will allow you to
enrich for molecules in that library
that may have drug like effects so not
only for delivery but also as drugs
themselves so if that's the case in the
process of whole animal selection if
this is the cross section of tissue that
I showed earlier if there's sufficient
chemical diversity you can potentially
minimize the the presence of that
biomarker over multiple generations and
so you can end up with an effective
treatment or Garris a cure so so as long
as there's sufficient molecular
diversity right it's possible to use
this molecular life
to effectively minimize that
pathological biomarker now in order for
this to work there needs to be several
key requirements for the selection
process first the molecules need to be
self-replicating apt Amar's are
self-replicating there needs to be an
animal model that exists that mimics the
human form of the disease whether it's
cancer some sort of tumor xenograph
model Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's or
whatever but but these animal models
must exhibit a characteristic phenotype
for visualization in order to take a
biopsy or to you know or laser capture
microscopy to cut out the that that
diseased area away from normal healthy
tissue so it in essence is possible to
target diseases of bacterial or viral
and origin or could we possibly target
other you know tissues or organs that
the brain possibly map the brain at
specific area for glioblastoma possibly
you know it as long as you can cross the
blood-brain barrier so you could
possibly influence behavior and has
cognitive abilities so that the
possibilities are endless in terms of of
using this approach of molecular
Darwinian evolution but in the whole
animal whether they're app Demers or or
other types of ligands but they must
meet these these criteria that's listed
on this slide here so towards that aim
or that ultimate goal we we've under we
have undertaken a simple experiment
where we we generated a library of of
apt immerse or randomized to pine floor
RNA similar strain a to pine floor RNA
library the reason its to prime fluoro
as we all know RNA is very susceptible
to degradation so there is a
analog of RNA in the two prime foot
position instead of a hydroxyl group
there's a fluorine atom and this floor
this two prime floor RNA chemistry
allows this this this RNA to being very
stable rock solid even more stable than
DNA in fact it has a half-life in serum
of 86 hours so we've we've taken a about
seed mouse tail vein injected a valve
alpsee Mouse with this library and our
negative whose sham control was a saline
injection of PBS into a mouse that did
not contain the library we collette at
post IV after after a certain amount of
time we sack the mouse collected various
organs and tissues harvested those
organs and tissues purified any any RNA
molecules that may be found at that in
each tissue and performed artis PCR and
in this again this flowchart of the
experimental design we hope to see a ban
on on a gel in the and with the the
mouse that has been injected versus no
ban on the Sham control so this is our
experimental setup to see if we can if
these molecules survive in vivo and if
we can amplify RNA species that that
that reside in those various organs and
tissues so just a very simple question
to see if if we can perform those
techniques and these are the actual
results from that experiment we tested a
panel of tissues and and and this
electrophoresis and gel run on positive
Lane and is our positive control a
negative Lane is is the the valve see
mouse that has that was only injected
with with a saline PBS
and we can see across the panel of
tissues we did receive you know just a
positive signal a yes signal yes no type
type this is a yes/no type analysis that
you know across all the panel tissues
that we've tested we did see a signal
which which is encouraging because you
know not only do these molecules survive
in a complex biological you know
organism but we're able to amplify any
any molecules that reside in those
tissues so then the next question is
okay well can we amplify molecules and
enrich for molecules that specifically
target one tissue versus another tissue
and so we chose one and below on the
right hand side the fourth quadrant on
the left on the right hand side of this
of this slide we quantitated the
enrichment of these AB Demers using
real-time PCR quantitative PCR the
y-axis indicates the enrichment ratio
and this is simply the amount of RNA we
were able to quantify using quantitative
PCR in that particular tissue relative
to the total bolus injection of the of
the library itself okay and the x-axis
indicates the rounds of selection or the
rounds that it went through this process
of the administration weighting a
certain period of time collection of
tissue and amplifying those molecules
and andrey injecting into into another
mouse so after you can see and rounds
and by the way the blue bar indicates
the signal from one the other colored
bars or the signal that from the other
tissues the panel tissues that we've
tested so you can see at generation five
six it
the signal from lawn has increased from
the early generations and by the time a
generation seven eight and nine it
started to plateau so at this point
we've determined that we've enriched the
library from a random state to a more
homogeneous polyclonal state that has a
general response the targeting LUN
versus the other tissues that we tested
in our panel and the signal-to-noise
here is approximately ten to one so the
library at that stage in generation nine
and a tenfold more preference towards
lung versus the other tissues so this
was interesting and so we decided to
stop the experiment there and and take a
peek at the sequence that the polynomial
sequence and and so we we've we've
sequenced that enriched pool and this
was back in the day when when we were
doing just you know Sanger sequencing
but now we have next-gen sequencing
capabilities so we can look at hundreds
of thousands if not millions of
sequences but here when we use
conventional sequencing techniques we
found that the sequences were grouped
into three different families down at
the bottom are the consensus sequence of
Group a group B and Group C and right
above that are the em fold secondary
structures of these families so that
that's the predictive secondary
structure of each of these consensus
sequences and above that is the
enrichment ratio comparing the library
their enriched g9 library versus
individual clones that we've sequence
that that matched the consensus sequence
and immediately you can see that the
clone g9c four is the most interesting
clone to further analyze that had the
highest signal towards lung verses
the other tissues so we decided to label
that particular clone and did and
forcing Li label I should say and
analyzed tissue sections using and situ
techniques under fluorescence microscopy
and we found that that particular Optima
clone did not bind to any of the panel
of tissues though we could not see
anything under the scope
except for lung and liver which is
surprising well actually not surprising
so so it one lit up and and we did see
some background fluorescence and liver
as well but we had to crank up this
exposure in order to show the the image
on this on the slide here so the act
actually the lung is twice as bright as
what you see with the liver here because
we had to crank it up twice as much in
terms of the exposure on the camera but
why is it why are we seeing residual
fluorescence and liver and there could
be one of two explanations the first is
that there might be a common epitope
where this this optima binds to that
exists both in the lung and the liver
but the most likely explanation is that
what we're seeing is byproducts or
degradation products everything passes
through the kidneys and liver and so
this is the the clearance of the
fluorescent fragments of these after
MERS through the liver so that's the
most likely explanation okay
so switching gears a bit I'd like to
introduce the concept of next-gen app
Demers or app top app to bodies as we as
we coined the term these are not
antibodies and it's not an app temir
it's an app the body so you can think of
it as a hybrid between the two so we
know I talked about the you know app
tubers third you know the there they're
single-stranded DNA or RNA there it's a
naked all ago nucleotide not much
chemistry besides the four bases adenine
thymine guanine and cytosine and we can
use the app diverse to specifically
target for Diagnostics or for as a drug
discovery tool and and and conjugate a
toxin radioisotope as I mentioned
earlier even or even a failed drug and
use it as a carrier and at the body is a
functionalized Optima so the Optima
itself is a it holds into position
functional groups and three-dimensional
space so it's a scaffold that holds
functional groups in three-dimensional
space so it's a super molecular
structure ok so this is this is the next
generation of apt immerse these these
these app the bodies that as we clean
the term so with that you can find very
interesting properties on this slide I
show as we know antibodies are protein
based they're the chemical alphabet of
antibodies are the twenty amino acids
now by definition app the bodies can
contain the twenty amino acids but in
also there is a possibility of using
fatty acids
carbohydrates organics and metal ions so
it has a wide variety of applications
not only in Diagnostics to improve
affinities in specificities but
therapeutics in terms of improving from
a kinetics or pharmacodynamics in terms
the drug drug delivery and drug
discovery in general but also are in
industrial applications so back to my my
model if this is your scaffold your
naked Optima right and let's say this
represents like an amino acids and an
amino acid a particular type of amino
acid and this represents a let's say a
small molecule or maybe yeah small mouth
or small organic or maybe even a sugar
this represents maybe a fatty acid okay
it's decorated with these functional
groups with the abdomen as a scaffold to
hold these functions in
three-dimensional space this is an apt
ibadi okay this will have much
interesting more interesting properties
and aptitude than just the naked app
temir itself because of the chemical but
it's much larger than that of Optimas
and even antibodies because we're
incorporated amino acids fatty acids
sugars you can imagine a scenario where
we're creating artificial enzymes that
do not exist in nature okay so we know
that enzymes are protein based and most
of the amino acids on these enzymes
these protein based enzymes is for
architecture to hold into place a few
amino acids that form a catalytic or or
a pocket that converts a substrate into
a product well if you generated a large
library of active bodies
each one with the unique shape and
decorated with different functional
groups and you interrogate that library
and you set up an assay to to isolate
enzymes that converts a particular
substrate into a product because you can
imagine a molecular solution in that
library that forms sort of like a
catalytic or write that can convert
possibly convert a substrate into
product that's the possibility that's
where the field of Akbar's are are going
using these these optimizer so we can
convert possibly you know cellulose in
you know as the substrate into some sort
of biofuel ethanol or just let your
imagination run wild in terms of in
terms of using these active bodies in
terms of industrial applications but the
key point here is that we're using again
principles of Darwinian evolution on a
molecular square a squiggle
and using chemical diversities to evolve
these molecules just to pass a certain
fitness test whether it's simple binding
or as a simple nano biotech application
so the strategy of separating winners
from the losers or binders from the non
binders is also a key requirement for
that so this last line is just just a
quick pitch that in terms of our company
we're a small biotech company and
south-central Pennsylvania as I
mentioned earlier and we do have
employment and postdoc opportunities and
with that thank you for your attention
and I can entertain any questions you
may have thank you
and thank you doctor dr. Jerome for that
informative presentation I'd also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 2019
as a final reminder dr. culture drone
will follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
and thank you for joining us we'll see
you again next time bye-bye